hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to buried now we're
beginning chapter 3 and continuing our
story down into the weird complex that
we're in and I'm not saying that this
has anything to do with SCP containment
breach but the parallels are still there
we follow Marcus into what can only
describe as a control room of sorts
there are countless computer screens
some of which are obviously coming back
on from having been shut off everything
looks extremely complicated from screens
filled with code and data to what is
obviously a security system it reminds
me of a miniaturized version of the
operation center in just about every
space travel movie I've ever seen Marcus
is running from one screen to another
apparently looking for some pertinent
bit of information where's the first-aid
kit I snap at him Marcus stops in his
tracks as if he'd forgotten the whole
reason for bringing us down here oh yeah
he says rushing to the left side of the
room there he hunkers down by an open
panel in the wall what I assume is the
emergency vault from where he got the
rifle I better I better look at that he
may be trying to grab another gun and
that probably wouldn't spell too much
good for me so I'm gonna look into that
appear over Marx's shoulder into the
baldies opened it's much larger than it
looks from the outside
it's partially filled with file folders
mark classified a few rounds of ammo for
a rifle a peculiar plastic kit filled
with syringes and a locked black box as
Marcus digs around one of the folders
flips open to the split second it's open
I see a scanned document in the color
photo the photo shows a male corpse with
its guts on the outside of its body as
if it had been turned inside out there's
also a massive swelling on his habit
almost like his skull is about to
explode
Marcus slaps the folder closed and then
I turn my attention to one of the
syringes it's filled with a violet
colored fluid that while rather pretty
in color looks deadly
Marcus finally pulls out the first aid
kit and turns around when I look back to
motion Denis over he's paler than ever
come on I tell him but he's not moving
from the plates on the floor where he
sits against the wall I slide the first
cade kid over to him and go scrambling
to his side between the struggle for the
rifle upstairs and arriving in this room
he's faded fast I struggled to lift up
his shirt and then over his shoulder as
the dried blood holds it in place the
mere act causes him to grimace
this might hurt a little I tell Dennis
he only knots he doesn't seem to care
Lou well I mean ripping off a band-aid
is one thing but this is an open wound
I mean gently might be good but ripping
it off quickly might also do some damage
I mean the common instinct would
probably be to rip it off quickly but
when it's a wound of this size I think
gently is the only way to go about it
yeah well apparently that was in Borden
I lift the shirt off gently and makes a
sucking sound there's so much blood that
the moisture tries to keep the shirt
pulled to him
Dennis lets out a little moan but seems
to relax in spite of his injuries with
the shirt fully removed the extent of
his injuries become more clear his wound
is more visible now although it's
partially hidden by the blood that just
started clawed around it
my medical knowledge is slim basically
just a bunch of basics I learned in Boy
Scouts I look over to Marcus hopefully
and ask you have any training zero he
says sorry it's just as well I guess
it's far too concerned with what's
happening on the monitors to be a much
help anyway
I start by taking out several rolls of
God's within the Kip and wipe as much
blood as I can't away from the wound on
his side it's even worse than I'd
figured from the start the gash is deep
I'm pretty sure it's infected too he's
going to need stitches that's for sure
but I have no idea how to even start
then besides I don't see the tools for
it in the kit when I splash rubbing
alcohol over the wound he responds with
a horse he yelled with surprise but
nothing more
his eyes are locked on me and he looks
appreciative but he's also scared be
honest dentist says hopefully how bad
did you look you think I'll live oh man
it looks really bad Dennis I mean it
does look bad but I've been reassuring
him this whole time
see I think he'll be fine he's gonna
pull through yeah
good to know he says but I sure don't
feel like that he been through hell I
say I think it feels worse than it
actually looks Thanks
that's a relief I won't lie you're gonna
have a scar I said trying to be funny he
chuckles a bit but there's no humor in
it he rests his head against the wall
and closes his eyes as I finish up I
placed one layer of god´s against the
wound and bind it with medical tape and
then reinforce it with the second layer
I know it's meagre but it's all I can do
thanks Roger he says actually managing
to force out a smile I feel a lot better
I think I'll be fine
I'm not so sure about that but I'm glad
I was able to encourage him finally I
patch up the bruises on the head a bit
cursing myself again for not grabbing my
hard hat I know I'm an idiot I look back
at Marcus and he's really looking back
at us deep in thought my eye is starting
to really swell up from where he kicked
me earlier maybe I shouldn't have let
him off so easy are the first-aid kits
all you have in this facility if there's
something better I don't know about it I
noticed then that its defensive postures
no longer there something is different
now
just a slight change in his demeanor he
seen something on those monitors that
hasn't frightened more than he already
was before what is it what's wrong
his eyes travel around the room and it's
obvious that he's trying to decide
whether or not to tell me the truth if I
ask him he's probably not gonna tell me
so I'm gonna take a look and look at
this rather than wait for him I get up
and scanned the screens behind him
seeing if I can find any clues I'd miss
moments go after a few moments I see a
few things that even I can comprehend
hidden into complex information most of
the screens on one screen I see what
looks like a power meter that's slowly
climbing upwards a single message is
flashing beneath it it reads unexpected
power failure for an entity another
message trickling along the bottom of a
black screen says safety locks on level
3 containment doors engaged override I
see still scenes on a few other screens
that I assume a security cameras showing
hallways and passages from elsewhere in
the facility one of them shows the first
level hallway we were on just a few
minutes ago another shows hallway I
don't recognize the floor is covered in
blood and just off the screen I see what
I think might be a human body but it's
bent in an impossible way it looks like
the body's legs in torso and somehow
been merged or melted into the floor is
it more important to say what's wrong
with the system's or is it more
important to say what is wrong with that
body on the ground that's melted into
the floor I'm kind of curious about that
I have no idea I didn't see it whatever
happened to that guy must have happened
in the last minute or so well that's not
good what the hell there's something
still happening are we so in danger he
turns away clearly fearing he has
already said too much
and as bad as that is there's a scene on
another monitor that makes my blood go
cold and my fear spiked a level
somewhere in your terror the scene is
very familiar it's the logging site the
equipment is unmistakeably mind I can
even see my truck something like fury
starts to rise up in my guts momentarily
pushing aside the fear for a moment I
consider just tearing into him a few
punches and a shove against the wall
nothing more I want answers and I want
them now but I'm not sure how which
would provide more answers asking calmly
or kicking his ass he is scared I'm
scared he's angry there's no reason to
escalate he knows us that's why in the
last episode he sorta saw some truth
when we said that we were loggers he
knew this he was watching us of course
they would they're complex they're going
to have security cameras all over the
location that they are to make sure that
no dumb lumberjack too stumbles his way
in I'm gonna ask him calmly could you
please explain to me why you've been
spying on my crew my anger is prodding
at me and I have to hold it back again
it's near the surf it's demanding a
release it was part of my job mine and a
few others your crew has been watched
ever since you set up your equipment why
because you're working with heavy
equipment some of which digs into the
ground less than a mile from a secret
government facility I had no idea of
that how could I have known Marcus gives
me that same crooked
trembling smile that's beginning to
creep me out because those things will
draw attention to this place you have no
idea how secretive this facility is
besides I know that the higher-ups
looked into it your site isn't on
government land it's shy by about 300
yards every piece of your equipment is
on private property the timber contract
you purchased from Minister Gladstone
two months ago so even if we wanted to
intervene and keep your crew away
we couldn't have without stirring up a
fuss the fact that someone with such a
low level clearance knows this much
about my logging crew is unnerving if
you've been watching us why didn't you
recognize us when we met in the hallway
I asked he shakes his head meg feels
like it's obvious the cameras don't have
a bird the cameras have a bird's-eye
view I can't see faces we just tracked
bodies in the night and names now that
is the point
probably the angers building up in this
guy in me because I want to know where
my crew is and this guy has probably
seen what happened unless the power went
out at the exact same time and he didn't
see what happened to my crew I mean I'm
angry I know that I want answers out of
this guy and this guy's a creep who's
never seen anybody but I still feel like
being calm is the only way to get out of
this I want to yell at him and if it
comes up one more time on the yell at it
but I'm gonna try to be calm about this
so since you have all this surveillance
do you know where the rest of my crew is
I do my best to keep my voice level even
though my impulse is to shout well all
of you were on site as usual before the
incident in a few hours since I checked
though they might have come near the
facility or maybe not I don't know he
says this casually like it's not
important well are they inside the
facility you have cameras everywhere
right do you see them Marga shakes his
head I've been looking all over and I
haven't seen your crew they aren't here
but the lower levels don't have any
cameras classified I'm not sure how they
would have gotten there but it's a
possibility I'm still shocked that we
were being watched they know everything
about us I'm telling you the depth of
influence in this facility goes deep
there are 36 employees down here outside
of those employees only five other
people know this place exists
yeah I'm done asking calmly I'm done
being jerked around with this guy not
giving the [ __ ] I'm gonna ask him what
the hell goes on here
he doesn't even pause to consider if he
should go any further
he actually laughs when he gives me the
answer I honestly don't know everything
probably very little but what I do know
is that is more than Black Hawks what
does that mean I asked there are
scientists here who have been disowned
by their own governments because of the
nature of their work you get it now
I don't not at all but I don't want him
to know that you said there are 36
employees where are they now he shakes
his head as far as I know everyone else
is gone gone where he points to the
screen that still informs us of
unexpected power failure in cringes if
this power failure was not corrected in
time there's no telling but they're here
in the facility somewhere right
I asked hoping someone will be able to
help Dennis better than I I just don't
know it could be anywhere look I say
furious with the ways talking in riddles
I don't ah God then it says I look over
to him and he's pale as a ghost he stood
up in his eyes or locked on the monitor
closest to him what he simply points to
the monitor and then looks away I look
at the monitor and see the logging site
but more specifically I see the
overturned dozer and the legs sticking
out from under it wearing work boots
right where I left him Tony the fact of
his death seemed to abstract almost like
it happened in some other world for very
long ago I know that you already told me
he was gone but it's different actually
seeing my god suddenly something blazes
by the open door outside the shape is
fast and in shadow but I'm pretty sure
it's a person someone else is here
Marcus says wheeling around he sounds
very happy to discover this so I try to
follow his lead if something bad
happened to this facility then surely
the site of another survivor is good
thing right
we should check it out he says I realize
this isn't the best moment to leave
Dennis after revisiting Tony's death all
over again someone just ran by the door
I don't
hopefully it's someone who can help us
I'm gonna ask him if he's gonna be okay
of course I care about this guy it's
fine go see who it is he says giving me
a mock phone
I turn to Marcus emotion us for us to
head out to investigate let's be careful
depending on who it is they might not be
as hesitant to shoot a stranger as I was
a nod at him as I head for the door I'm
still holding the rifle in my hand and I
don't know if I have the guts to
actually use it if needed was the final
look back to Dennis I've run out into
the second-level hallway continued man
we're going deep into this that's the
thing about this it's so enthralling to
see this story spread out well that's
not reassuring and the subtleties of the
sound is good Marcus follows there's
still fear in his eyes but also the
slightest glimmer of hope that hope is
contagious we take off after the figure
that just ran past the command center
ahead of us the facility presents yet
another long hallway right away I notice
that on this level of this facility
seems darker even though the lights are
all on now the hallway is adorned with
numbered yellow doorways and large white
panels along the walls it's clean and
well maintained but there's something
ominous about it up ahead I see the
fleeting motion of something dark
cutting quickly to the left down a
corridor there I say quietly pointing up
ahead Marcus gives a nod and we continue
chasing after the person we saw blazed
by the command center just a few moments
ago it occurs to me that this person
could be like Marcus at first armed and
scared maybe best not to shout in this
hallway I mean I know I have a
proclivity to shout and maybe I should
just keep going with that but uh you
know you never know you never know I'm
gonna shout at a pawn shop hey hey hey
if you buddy
hey stop who's there I get no response
and I'm unsure if I should be relieved
or upset by this
the last person we met nearly killed me
with a rifle why would this person be
any different I quickly dart around the
corner and take some shooting the same
shooting stance I've seen countless
times on TV there's a woman standing
there about ten feet away
she has reddish blond hair and a small
mouth he billed she looks terrified in
his visibly shaking she's probably in
her late 30s wearing a lab coat with
dark jeans and green converse low tops
I have a strange sense that her fear is
not just about our sudden appearance she
looks like a woman who's been running
scared for a while her hands are raised
in surrender she's not holding a weapon
Markus slowly approaches taking a few
steps ahead of me
it's Amy right he asks she blinks
seemingly surprised that he knows her
name yes and you're mark Marcos she nods
absently and then looks to my little
rifle I'm not going to use it she's
obviously scared I was worried that this
wasn't even going to be a human that we
find I'm not going to use it but Markus
knows her now how do I know that she
asks you're trespassing on government
property in the midst of a huge
catastrophic event and you have a rifle
how am I supposed to believe you I have
a friend back in the command center who
needs medical attention and we're
looking for the rest of our crew I'm
really sorry but I don't know where they
are she says do you know what's happened
from the power outage I don't know what
caused it she says but there was an
experiment picking place when the outage
occurred something happened then she
trails off here giving me a look of
distrust I saw things on the security
monitors the experiment failed didn't it
I don't know the specifics I barely
escaped the third floor I was going to
go to the command center to see if the
security footage showed anything but
then I saw you and the gun listening to
their conversation I'm feeling totally
in the dark what has you so scared is
more important and probably gets more
pertinent to the matter at hand what the
hell is so scary
Amy looks to me her eyes widen terrified
who are you anyway
I quickly give her my story a logger
stranded in the woods falling of
peculiar explosion at the logging site
as I tell her recognition blooms in her
eyes if one of the loggers yes she then
looks to Marcus and says I thought they
were being watched
they were this is a freak accident
there's no proof they were responsible I
feel myself wanting to submit to all the
questions that are piling up in my head
but dennis is waiting for me
see I gotta get medical attention for
Dennis that's like first priority she
can in any way help I decided to despite
my curiosity I need to get Dennis help
as soon as humanly possible look is
there any medical help to be had here or
not
probably Amy says but you'd have to find
Colonel Barksdale he knows we're all
those sorts of supplies are where is he
where is everyone else at this Amy
starts to weep she falls to her knees as
if someone instructors her behind
gone she says some were killed and some
were just I don't know they disappeared
right in front of me what the hell is
going on here something's here with us
Amy says we were conducting an
experiment and it all went horribly
wrong something came through came
through what Marcus asks I don't even
know that much an entity but whatever it
is it's still here somewhere how could
you not know
don't you have full security ask us
access no I have access to almost
everything but there are two levels of
security beyond my clearance so what do
you suggest we do now I'm not sure she
says wiping her tears away but if you
want to find your crew we need to find
Barksdale he's in charge where is he
down on the third level in the hangar
and let's go it's not that easy and he
says again looking to the rifle in my
hand why not like I said something came
through when the power went out there's
several of them all roaming the third
level what came through what is it all I
know is that the others refer to them as
entities Amy shudders as she recalls the
horror she has seen I don't even know
how to describe them I didn't get a good
look all I did was run for my life
behind me I just heard screams I know
it's not very scientific of me but I
didn't feel like sticking around to
learn more
she's ride Marcus says stopping my train
of thought the things I saw on the
monitors it was crazy
this is insane I barked I'm going to the
third level to find this barksdale guy
thanks for your help
wait Marcus said I'm sticking with you
if we want to get out of here we have to
find Barksdale right
yes a Barksdale's on the third floor and
it's too dangerous to go back there I
figure I'll let them make their own
decisions in the meantime I start
heading back to the command center to
get Dennis before I get there I hear
their footfalls behind me getting closer
I give Amy a questioning look and she
quickly looks away clearly torn neither
of you know your way around here looking
for Barksdale on your own would be
suicide like it or not she has a point
fine and let's go get Dennis from the
command center and head down together
yeah
that's not their split up that's like
the last thing that you should do but I
don't even know if dennis is going to be
able to move dennis is like really hurt
it's not even any painkillers for him
we entered the command center and I'm
happy to see the Dennis's we've gained
some of his color we're going to get you
some help I tell them and then we're
gonna find our crew and get the hell out
of here more help would be great he says
with the way you took an hour to get my
shirt off earlier I'm not letting you
touch me again wait maybe one of us
should stay here with him I'll be okay
he stands to his feet with a grunt you
don't know what's out there I saw them I
saw what they can do this facility is
not safe
are there any of them on this floor I'm
not sure but they're down on the third
floor so we'll need to be careful Marcus
looks a little hesitant but he nods his
agreement in the four of us exit the
command center heading back out in the
hallway I look back to the monitors I
take a final look at the screen that
shows my wrecked logging site and I feel
pang of sorrow then I looked at the
other monitors showing live feed of the
facility's security cameras I tried to
tell myself that I'm not looking for any
sign of Amy's creatures but I can't
that's exactly what I'm doing
and there's no need to pretend otherwise
we head back through the hall and
towards the elevator the tension exists
between us is like a physical presence
seems like a bad idea we step inside the
elevator and those pristine doors closed
inside the elevator Amy seems to become
much more guarded and distant from us I
want to assure that I mean err no harm
but I'm also not going to put the rifle
down who you have pretty high clearance
in this place right that's right so what
kind of experiment are we talking about
here when when wrong when she starts to
answer my question I can tell that it's
something for a relief of her for her to
get some of it off her chest there's
been a lot of work on the project taking
place over here over the last three
years or so the purpose is to find out
if there's any real viable science
behind point-to-point instant creation
like teleporting oh my god I had no idea
I knew there was some weird stuff here
but nothing this insane it's really not
all that is same we found our first
major breakthrough about nine months ago
we were able to transport a live rat
from its caves on level 3 to a small lab
in New Mexico the trick took the rat
five seconds are you kidding me I can
tell that he wants to sound as if he's
mocking the idea but he fails he's
scared not at all
the problem was that when the rat
arrived its retinas were detached and
its intestines were on the outside of
its body what does this have to do with
us now well about six months ago we
successfully made the same experiment
the rat arrived in great health and this
time in just three seconds still one of
the things that we needed to tweak in
order to make the process completely
safe was to figure out how to keep the
subject on a straight course when the
matter is being transported not only are
its atoms being unknit and then put back
together upon arrival unknit that's
exactly the way the star Trak does it
yeah
deconstructed and translated through
space it's the only way we know how to
do it right now but the issue as I said
comes in keeping the deconstructed
subject on a straight course to its
destination when the process occurs we
are deforming space-time we're creating
a shortcut through space and that has
risks why exactly Denis asks because
there are many more dimensions in space
than the three we exist on she explains
there's some evidence to say that there
are as many as 10
so when you send a rat to New Mexico
it's traveling through another dimension
to get there I asked basically and
because of that we're trying to get a
better understanding of what these other
dimensions are capable of things that
have a great deal of population would be
scared of if they knew what we were
doing and saw the privacy then today the
power went out went out as we were right
in the middle of an experiment something
happened
what I don't know to be speaking with
the authority of someone who knows what
she's talking about
is that why those creatures are here
that's my assumption I wasn't present
for the experiment I'm not cleared for
such things but I do get reports what
reports Marcos acts I'm given access to
the result of the test
in other words Marcos replies clearly
upset you guys have been peeking into
other dimensions and taking notes on
what you see I can't believe that I've
wasted my life for this he murmurs to
himself he looks like he's starting to
freak out
amy is quiet her expression indicates
that she's waiting to see how I react
all this see honestly that's incredible
like legitimately that's that's
legitimately incredible that's um that's
groundbreaking science like legitimately
so this is like interdimensional stuff I
asked in a way Amy answers Marcos on the
other hand is incredulous I don't want
anything to do with this he says all
this time I've been working for for he
laughs cruelly in the sound of it makes
my blood go cold for a second just a
single level beneath my feet you
[ __ ] have been tearing apart space
and time Marcos continues when the
elevator doors open I can't get out fast
enough the tension is growing way too
thick for my liking outside of the
elevators we step out into what appears
to be massive industrial area the
Carnot's waiting for us it's unlike
anything I've seen in the upper levels
oh boy II oh that's not good oh that's
not good oh that's the opposite
the area looks industrial like
everything was built for utility only
but more noticeable than that is all of
the blood my god I've never seen so much
blood in those creatures must have had a
field day
holy [ __ ] Marcus says looking like a man
that just awoke from a very bad dream
there were more personnel in this area
when the experiment went haywire Haney
he says and if the explanation makes it
all better the research you had to do
all down here better be worth it I say
we had to get moving or we're gonna lose
our nerve Amy let's focus Barksdale's in
the hangar I asked if he's still alive
yes that's where he'll be then let's
hurry I say as far as I can tell dennis
is doing much better but I'm beginning
to grow tired of trying to keep my fear
at bay between the blood on the floor
the silence in level three and Amy's
talk of the lab rats I'm getting freaked
out no no I can take it I am a brave boy
I can do this I've got the gun Jesus I'm
not gonna let in when walk in front of
me with a gun the four of us start
walking head with me in the lead we stop
walking when we come to the remains of
what looks to be three different people
it's hard to tell how many bodies were
there were because they've been torn to
shreds inert distorted two of the bodies
look as if they've been fused together
another man looks to have his leg welded
to the floor I can see this man's face
he died in an abject state of horror his
mouth pried open in an eternal scream we
got to investigate the bodies but we
have to is grim work but we have to know
I see half a face pushed down into the
floor like putty
barely attached to a separated skull a
single dead eye stares at me I think I'm
like puke behind me Marcus does just
that as I listened to him heaving my
eyes cannot leave the carnage this blood
everywhere
a crimson pool flooding the floor there
are hunks of skin and tissues splattered
on the wall and a strand of unspooled
intestine that clings to the floor like
a dead snake Jenna steps up beside me
and when he speaks his voice is soft and
flat what in the hell could do that to
someone
the things I saw 80 answers they could
do it pretty easily I think she looks
pale and I think that she may pass out
at any moment
tears spill from her eyes and she's
visibly shaking but she soldiers on
looking back to me and stepping to the
side of the gruesome carnage her eyes
again go to my rifle and she doesn't
look very hopeful you good to go she
asks me we need to move on but for some
reason I can't take my eyes off the
scene my mind is reeling trying to
process it all I don't know if I keep
looking around then we're gonna stick
around in this area and that may be too
long and also it might be bad for the
group I mean is there anything to glean
more than what we've seen already there
could be a key or that could be
something but I don't think that I don't
think the group can take it we got to
get out of here we leave the grisly
sight behind moving into an equally
destroyed area from what I can tell the
next room was once an open area for ins
experimentation the place hasn't just
been destroyed it's been physically
altered in a way that makes no sense the
girders look to have been warmed the
very materials distorted and twisted to
my right a machine has been catapulted
and looks to have somehow merged with
the wall rather than crashing into it
beyond these phenomena there's a
standard violence I was expecting to see
there's a limp arm sticking out from
underneath the wreckage and more blood I
see no signs of an explosion which makes
me wonder just how this happened
seeing the aftermath is sickening enough
but it makes me wonder if Amy saw it
while it was happening did you see what
happened to those girders I don't need a
reminder about the people to die I only
caught a glimpse of it it was like
trying to focus your eye on something
that was too close
they just started twisting but not
creaking or breaking it's like these
creatures are able to deform
she pauses here and that's when we hear
something echo through the facility
it comes from highness and slightly to
the right I'm not sure what it is but it
makes my blood feel like ice it sounds
almost like static from an AM radio but
there's a high-pitched noise beneath it
that I can't even start to fathom what
in the hell is that I asked instantly
clapping my hands to my ears one of them
she says her voice will whisper one of
the creatures that's what they sound
like Dennis asks I see that he's leaning
against the wall wincing at the noise I
suddenly realized that I have a death
grip on the rifle ready to shoot it the
next thing I see anything between us and
them
not really none of the hallways blocked
off by secure doors everyone seems to
take this as the cue to start moving
again we make our way around the office
wreckage now with new purpose in our
step we barely make it to the other side
of the room approaching a dark hallway
when another high-pitched noise sounds
out this one is louder closer we all
share a terrified look and I can tell
that amy is on the verge of losing it I
gripped my tight rifle tightly as we
head towards the hallway in front of us
how much further did anger close it's
just at the end of this hallway then it
speaks up its voice like ice why don't
we just haul ass then no one says
anything after that but I can feel the
presence of terror around us pressing in
on us like some new violent gravity we
have
I'm out of here this is a bad place to
be caught out in the open that is even
more blood this is blood everywhere
the small utility hallway is well lit it
looks as if it was designed to only be
used by select maintenance workers what
goes on in this area I asked I'm looking
at markets and I ask questions but the
only shrugs in response she might know
he replies pointing to a me I've never
been down here before
it's just a utility hallway but at the
end of the maintenance room there should
be a gun or two in that it's also the
most direct path to the hangar entrance
as we walk quickly and quietly down the
hall I take a glimpse ahead and feel the
hair on the back of my neck stand on end
the lights become more sparsely spaced
and it's impossible to see the South far
down the hall extends into the darkness
this hallway has the occasional trace of
bloodshed but nothing like the main area
we've come from we continue farther down
and just as I begin to see with the
largest what looks like a large metal
door for their head and here yet another
shrill sound this one sounds farther
away but no less demonic how many of
these things did you see three but
that's just what I saw there could be
more what did they look like yeah what
are we dealing with I don't want to I
don't want to ignore this I don't even
know how to explain them monsters that's
the only word I can think of my mind
seemed to struggle just trying to
understand what I've seen they're big
and we seen the jerk around every few
feet or so it looked like they're made
of light that's about all I know for
sure you know
my ex-husband always said I'd let my
work kill me she continues singly unable
to stop herself I mean I doubt he
imagined this exact scenario but still
as we make our way to the hangar doors
another high-pitched scream rings out
angrier now Amy stops walking causing
all of us to stop and turn to her we
have to do something to slow those
things down
no there's no time we need to distance
ourselves and get to the hangar fast
Amy ignores him deep in thought there's
an old hydraulic door set into the wall
right here it hasn't been used for years
though she looks to me pleading her case
together we might be able to pull it
close behind us to keep those things
back those old hydraulic doors weigh a
ton there's no way it'll work Roger what
do you think the harder time getting to
us if these doors are locked
look Marcus chefs we need to get to the
hangar now okay
there's one person in this group that
had survived these things and that's Amy
I don't know if it's blind luck or
actual intelligence but I'm guessing
that she knows what she's supposed to do
we're gonna close those damn doors
damn it Marcus says we don't have time
for this Amy ignores them starts feeling
along the hallway for Dennis and I start
looking as well a minute passes then I
see a small metal frame that runs from
the floor to the ceiling it's a suicide
is this it I asked yes Amy says I looked
at the floor and see an old metal track
that runs along the frame let's move it
I say Amy Dennis and I start pulling as
hard as we can but it barely touches an
inch behind us the static noise brings
out my heart seems to stutter and mark
lets out a little wine we're running out
of time we need to go those things are
getting closer every second help us
market if Margaret's just gets off his
ass and help us it won't make a
difference we shut up and help us and
then we'll find out I shall reluctantly
mark walks over and grasp the door we
all groan as we strain to pull it starts
inching slowly and then begins moving
steadily once we get it started it
slides easily as we near the wall
closing off the hallway behind it I can
I think I can see the merest glimpse of
an odd illuminated shape in the darkness
it's cut off by the slight thump of the
hydraulic door being pushed against the
frame in the Ottoman wall
Amy turns the lock into place great now
let's haul ass says Marcus we all turn
and get moving again still feeling
unsure about our prospects the fact that
yet another shrill noise sounds about
elsewhere in the facility is not calming
and then there are two of them it's
almost like they're calling out to one
another the doors to the hangar set up
ahead like an entrance to some enormous
labyrinth I think we made the right
choice but that does not look promising
this blood right on that hangar door it
seems to be empty when we reach that
hangar door I get a true sense of how
impenetrable they are the computer
terminal is mounted on the wall nearby
and as a blinking red light any idea
what this means I ask it's an automated
lock a fail-safe from the lockdown it
says Amy I've never been down here
before Marcus says if I known the store
was here I would have opened it earlier
how Amy asks the fear in her voice is
more present than ever from the command
center you need the override from there
first then use this terminal to open the
hangar doors the command center on the
second floor I ask ya Amy shakes her
head and lets out a nervous laugh are
you kidding me we just pulled that
hydraulic door and blocked off the
hallway remember if we want to get into
the hangar we have to get back to the
command center there another way
turning the Marcus Amy replies well
there's another elevator but we'll need
to go to bio chem storage I need to stay
with Dennis so he can rest you two go
you know your way around this place and
you know the controls Marcus fine but
we'll need to be armed Oh
the thing is Amy doesn't know how to use
the gun Marcus does he's been trained
for that as much as I don't like Marcus
he's the one qualified to do it amy is a
scientist what training would she have
in that then again I like I do trust Amy
more but I can't be guaranteed that
Marcus isn't gonna do something stupid
god damn it oh this is a bad choice this
is a bad choice but I think I'm gonna
give it to Marcus just because just
because Marcus has had the training and
then again I don't know if Amy doesn't
have the training Marcus didn't shoot us
that's the thing he had enough
self-control even though he was scared
not
you toss I don't know what Amy would do
I'm just going to give it to Marcus -
vainly could be like it's Soul Survivor
instinct but then again Marcus could be
- when I give it to Marcus it's his gun
anyway
a hand markets the rifle and he turns to
go Amy gives me a concerned look but
follows along behind him once a me and
Marcus made a good good distance down
the hallway Denis lets out a little
nervous laugh and then there were two he
says then it looks much better but he
still needs to use the wall to stay
standing
didn't Amy say that there were guns and
emergency kits in the maintenance from
near the hangar doors I asked yeah I
think so Dennis says looking exhausted I
look ahead and see a door to the right
to read the maintenance might as well
give it a try
I go to the door try to open it and find
that it's locked no I don't want to kick
it down my knees bad my knees bad I'll
push it with my shoulder my knee is bad
I give it a hard shove but it doesn't
budge I'm about to try again but that's
when I hear the dried choking sound from
just down the hallway
it's barely audible but it's not my
imagination
my first thought it's one of those
things one of the monsters but after
calming my nerves and reassessing it
sounds more like a person I think about
how angry and on edge amy was when she
turned to leave as well as how scared
Marcus looked alarm bell sound in my
head and before I know it I'm heading
back down the hall away from the hangar
doors stay here I'll be right back I
whisper over my shoulder it's damaged
see if you can figure out how to give me
the mainland where you going hissed I
don't bother answering it was not bound
to the door where a me and Marcus went
no did I make a goof I better not have
made a goof that's a lot of blood
I would have heard a gunshot as I
entered the biochem room and start
walking between the massive silos
I wonder what classified chemicals could
be inside of them I'm fully expecting
one of Amy's creatures to come flying
out from the intersection of halls
instead I think I hear something a
skittering noise like something moving
quickly I run ahead so fast that I
almost tripped over two people and a
life-or-death struggle my mind tries to
process what I'm seeing but it makes no
sense none at all
Markus is on the floor with Amy pinned
beneath him he has this rifle at a
throat pushing her down to the floor and
choking her with it her face is turning
purple and her eyes look like they may
pop out of her head
Marco Cena sees me coming down the
hallway but acts as if what he's doing
is perfectly normal I got to stop him
what the hell is he doing I start
rushing towards him before I really know
what I'm doing I bring my fish down hard
in an arc across the bridge of his nose
and rewarded with a sick cracking sound
he cries out as he falls to the ground
looking at me as if he doesn't
understand why I punched him on the
floor
Amy clutches at her neck and glass
grasps for breath I start to fear that I
was a moment too late just as I see the
rifle had been thrown across the floor
Marcus seems to know this at the exact
same moment that I do I'm gonna hit
Marcus agains you this guy deserves to
be hit I deliver a surprisingly strong
blow with my right hand clipping his
chin from my awkward position I'm in the
process of planting an e in its chest to
hold him down with his left foot comes
out of nowhere landing hard the kick
catches me squarely in the ribs knocking
the breath out of me what the hell are
you doing a killing her I'm saving us
all all of this was her fault I sense
that he truly believes this but if
that's the case then why not just shoot
her rather than Strangler with the rifle
the answer is simple we would have heard
the gunshot and I or those things would
have come running he wanted to kill her
quietly and then what would he have done
the same to Denison me it seems fitting
really when we first came akan Marcus he
held a gun on us I've been so relieved
to see another human being that I'd
underestimated just how unhinged he was
Marcus and I both died for the rifle but
he's still laying on the floor and start
wrestling for professor possession but
I'm not confident he'll come away with
it as we struggle he starts inching the
muzzle of the gun towards my face a
position I do not want to be in I start
pushing back hard
if this thing accidentally fires I'm not
sure where I'd prefer the bullet to go
especially in this room full of chemical
tanks
horse muzzle towards Marcus oh boy oh
boy
what the [ __ ] is going on what the [ __ ]
is going on
I grunt as I push the muzzle to point
towards his face realizing he's
literally looking down the barrel of a
gun
Marcus ducks his head out of the way
this makes him lose leverage allowing me
to yank the gun from his grip I get to
my feet as quickly as I can swinging the
rifle back around on him for a moment I
think I've knocked him out but his eyes
flutter and he looks to me as if I
betrayed him for people it was them that
did this she deserves to die she did
this
I look to Amy and wish I could help her
I'm relieved to see that she's managed
to draw on a few breaths her legs move
as she tries to push herself into a
sitting position she wouldn't know you
didn't work here under there secrecy you
don't know what it was liked he
surprises me by lunging towards me
leaping from the floor like a human
projectile I don't have time to aim
carefully I have to react fast like I
can't shoot him that would defeat the
entire purpose of this I have to try to
dodge but he's probably going to hit my
knee that's gonna be damaging but it's
better than shooting him his aim is
pouring the strength is failing so I
dodged him easily oh okay then I don't
want to have a gun shot go off and alert
those creatures to where we are make a
hard jab of the butt of the rifle
striking them in the chest something
that crunches and he lets out a whoosh
of air it crumbles for a moment and then
goes to his knees it roars and pain on
the floor only after a few moments I
realize that they're not purely screams
of pain the bastard is calling for them
calling for those creatures to come for
us this place is evil along with
everyone involved if you take it or
taking her side then you deserve to die
too if you want to stop me you'd better
do it now you coward the rage in his
eyes at Amy's as well as towards me for
stopping and makes me think that he'll
deliver on his threat I'll raise the
rifle again every urge in my body
wanting to make sure he doesn't come
back to bite us
I'm not a violent man I could not easily
kill him and just leave him behind I'm a
forgiving guy but this is ridiculous
like he's obviously scared and unhinged
it's not like he's possessed too by bit
the demons he's just not thinking
rationally he's been in complete
solitude for months at a time maybe even
a year just in this place alone with no
one telling him what's going on and he
finds out that it's something that he
staunchly opposes if I if I kill him
that I'm shooting him and it defeats the
purpose anyway god I don't want to I
don't want to just like one I could
barely shoot earlier as he was coming at
me I can't bring myself to deliver a
kill shot I ignored him and leaned down
to Amy you okay I asked she not slowly
have to go she says they'll be here any
minute
too much noise I have to hold her arm so
she can get to her feet we start forward
and then I think of Dennis we should go
back to the hangar doors I can't just
leave Dennis there there's no time you
need to come with me up to the command
center now we'll be back for him soon
you're all dead now anyway Marcus
shrieks if they don't get you I will he
laughs maniacally after saying this
hooting like a madman as if in response
to high-pitched noise tears through the
hallway I seem to feel it in my bones
they're following his noise now she
takes off away from Marcus presumably
towards the other elevator she'd
mentioned moments ago I follow her as we
move out I hear Marcus slowly pushing
himself off the ground and stumble off
slipping in between the tanks and
disappearing we start running and after
the few first strides another noise
sounds out sounds mechanical but at the
same time it also reminds me of the
recordings I've heard of whale songs
sound of metallic creaking and crashing
echoes suit the door I came in through
it reached the hydraulic door we pulled
him Amy says the sound grows louder and
it's clear they're struggling with it
which is good we have a bit more time I
speed up my step to follow Amy as he
leads me away to the other elevator
she's panting furiously
a song I can hear something rattling in
a breath likely the result of Marcus's
attacks this makes me imagine how this
cold uncaring eyes must have looked
staring down at her as you tried to
deliver her to death how she's still
forging on is beyond me I'm sorry about
Marcus I it's not your fault when you
handed him the gun you didn't know he
would use it on me I just hope we can
find a way to survive this mess we'll be
fine
don't worry that's me the reassuring guy
I'm not so sure she says her eyes stick
straight ahead I'm not sure I can blame
her I just wanted to say something
encouraging I guess we finally come to
the elevator at the end of a row of
silos the elevators door slides open
slowly the moment we hear something
behind us a strangled sort of whistling
sound we step inside and turn around to
face the bio chem room thankfully we've
been getting a few moments to spare the
elevator doors remain open for three
seconds before they start to slide close
again in those three seconds I see a
large shape floating towards us a
phosphorescent like white glow outlines
an impossible shape behind it
I see another shape that's also entered
the bio chem room and another the third
one breaks away from the other two
taking a quick right it moves with eerie
speed that's the direction Marcus had
gone honestly the thought of them
hunting down doesn't bother me in the
slightest Amy is pressing the button to
close the elevator doors over and over
but they stay open for what seems like
an eternity I curse whoever designed
these damn doors I don't think honestly
if they're made of light I don't think
those are going to do a damn thing
against him we're going to hide in here
a Meany I slide ourselves up against the
sides of the elevator trying to avoid
being seen but I came to help with
peeking around the corner
I'll hold the rifle steady ready to fire
and that's when I see them clear light
for the first time I can see their
features their shape and their colors
but my mind can't quite process at all
nothing about them makes any sense my
eyes try to see a squid but that's not
what I'm these things are they're gray
and white and seem to be nothing more
than squirming light their appendages
are neither legs nor tentacles but
somewhere in between they don't walk on
these appendages they just use them to
glide
they move like ghosts and seem to jerk
every few feet or so but I'm pretty sure
that this jerking is I could not a
result of their moving but my minds the
inability to understand how they're
moving
exactly it's also more than their
appearance that makes a mockery of
reality the light around them seems to
bend inward as if the space within the
room is to reshape itself for their
existence that peculiar effect on the
air makes their movements seem like
something moving underwater and faster
they screech in unison they rush toward
the elevator
they'll be inside here in another few
seconds I checked the rifle and see that
my ammo is diminishing I have to charge
saving my shots I'm going to have to be
choosing but wait I haven't shot it yet
it's never been a shot oh man I have
full faith that this elevator is going
to close but should I shoot at them they
already know I'm here they're right in
front of me at least if I shoot at them
I'll know if it affects them that's
important if they're saying my ammo is
diminishing but I haven't used my
bullets yet I did not shoot Marcus I
think I can spare a bullet at this one
you decide to shoot at the creatures now
about a foot remains between sliding
doors I find my muscles reenact reacting
instinctively again I pulled the trigger
the shop fills the elevator and there's
a thunder in my ears I hit the thing in
the center and the reaction is not what
I expect the monster pauses and spasms
for about two seconds its body's light
flickers for a moment similar to a light
bulb on the brink of burning out my
finger keeps pulling the trigger the
throb of the rifle in my hand is
comforting and each screech from the
creatures like music then I realized
that this only seems to be slowing it
down its tentacles seem to tighten and
then loosen it like a weird muscle
reflex but then it's on the move again
unharmed by the shots
finally the elevator door closes the
creatures wash against the other side of
the door making an electrical noise and
crying out manga
the tips of their spider-like appendages
poked through the wall an elevator door
but for some reason they can't get all
the way through Amy screams have
different curls and to evolve the far
end of the elevator crime
I say nothing to her I just cling to the
rifle hoping those creatures don't find
Dennis as he waits about a hangar doors
where I left him for his sake in ours we
need to get them open now end of chapter
3 wow this was a long one this was
actually a long one we made a lot of
choices here I want to see how I stack
up against everybody else because this
was quite a chapter the blunt truth UN
59% of players told Dennis he'd probably
be fine
slow them down you and 35 percent of
players sided with Amy on pulling the
hydraulic door who to trust you and 31
percent of players gave the gun to
Marcus
let's see you and 58% of players left
Marcus alive now or later you and 32% of
players used your ammo and took extra
shots at the creatures so I I was kind
of on the outside of the norm here but
it seems to me that no matter if you
gave it to Amy or Marcus it doesn't
matter because Marcus would have tried
to kill her anyway because murderer
Murphy seems to be there I think I made
some good choices I really do but maybe
maybe not but we shall see in the next
episode there's only two chapters left
so it's getting down to the wire and
things are getting very dire I don't
know if Dennis is going to survive this
he's down there alone but then again
Marcus is probably going to die because
one of those things went right for him
it beelined for him so I don't think
he's going to be able to get away from
that I think we're gonna find Marcus his
corpse very soon but Dennis if he could
get into that maintenance closet and get
a gun maybe he has a chance but I'm not
under century but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]